Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 3 is
the long night the army of the Dead
attacks Winterfell the living are
Daenerys and John with dragons the
Dothraki and unsullied armies of the
north veil and wildlings and almost
every other living character bran is
with Theon in the godswood because the
plan is to lure the night king and kill
him to end the war so the whole gangs
here fighting to save the world and they
use some questionable battle tactics
their trebuchet czar in front of their
defenses so they only get to fire once
before they're overwhelmed and useless
the infantry are in front of the
trenches so the trenches don't protect
them in fact they get in the way of the
retreat
you'd think everyone just should have
stayed in Winterfell defending the
castle because that's what castles are
for there are lots of weird tactics this
episode made for the sake of heightening
of the drama Melisandre arrives she left
for volantis last season and some fans
hoped that she had returned with an army
or other red priests Melisandre doesn't
bring allies but she does bring fire
magic setting a light the Dothraki
weapons
it sure is lucky she came because those
Dothraki are acts armed Valyrian steel
or dragon glass so they would have been
pretty useless against the dead if Mel
hadn't shown up Melisandre is confronted
by Davos he once promised to execute Mel
because she burned his friend Shireen
she says there's no need to kill her
because she'll die tonight there's this
great shot of Melisandre shadow in the
light
Melisandre believes in just good and
evil black and white with nothing in
between but ironically Melisandre is one
of the most morally grey characters in
the series she does great things and
terrible things and everything in
between
the Dothraki charge lights in the
darkness like stars that blink out one
by one as the Dothraki die it's a
terrifying apocalyptic image that also
evokes Dothraki religion the Dothraki
believe that when they die their spirit
becomes a star riding a fiery horse
across the night sky the
more fiercely a man burns in life the
brighter his star shines so it's all the
more horrifying that those fiery
Dothraki are extinguished in pitch
darkness the short runners say this is
the end of the Dothraki which is a
pretty bleak end to their journey
Daenerys spent whole seasons winning the
trust of the Dothraki she learned to be
a Khaleesi and led her khalasar through
the Red Waste in season six she returned
to the Dothraki and gathered a massive
army declaring them all her personal
blood riders to cross the Seas and
conquer as no other Dothraki had to be
hers now and always but ten minutes into
this battle
they're all dead we never got to see the
Dothraki perspective on foreign Westeros
or how the Dothraki habit of boning and
raiding would fit in Danny's regime
there weren't even any named Dothraki
this season unless you count kono and no
one counts kono so this is a sad sudden
end to the people who shaped so much of
Daenerys story if the plan is to keep
the Dragons out of combat until the
night King comes but when Danny sees the
Dothraki die she abandons the plan and
she and Jon burn some zombies as they
should have from the start
Jon tries to attack the White Walkers
who lead the dead but the walkers
conjure a storm that blows him back
similar to the storm at hardhome the
dead crash into the living like an
unstoppable force of nature Jaime
Brienne pod torment beric Hound Gendry
Sam and Eid are all on the front lines
and somehow they all survive this
except for Ed which is just his luck ri
pay to the 999th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch
the fighters realized that this castle
thing was a good idea after all
so they retreat into Winterfell while
the unsullied hold back the dead the
unsullied are uniquely qualified for
this sort of thing in Game of Thrones
history a group of 3,000 unsullied
famously held off an army of Dothraki at
qohor $20,000 a key broke on the
unsullied like waves on a rocky shore so
the unsullied are really good at this
they can only last so long against the
dead so grey worm closes the trench
behind his men sacrificing them so very
early in this battle most of the nurses
army is destroyed at dothraki and
unsullied are mostly gone so afterwards
Daenerys will need the support of the
north more than ever the living try to
light the trench with fiery torches it's
like a reverse of helms deep from Lord
of the Rings the torches fail so
Melisandre steps up Mel had a crisis of
faith after Stannis died in season 5 she
regained some confidence when she
resurrected John and now she calls on
her God to give her fire and the
trenches light so Melisandre is filled
with faith she believes that her God has
a plan in the godswood bran uses his
walking powers to control some Ravens
and he flies them up to the night King
on his zombie dragon it's unclear if
bran is trying to get the Night Kings
attention or if he's just having a
look-see or what but bran spends the
rest of the battle in warg mode doing
nothing that we can say which seems like
a waste of his powers bran spent six
seasons learning magic to fight the
White Walkers and now he's not using his
powers he doesn't walk a dragon or have
some important vision or tell anyone
anything useful it seems as though bran
knows the future he knows how this
battle will end so he's just sitting and
watching while destiny runs its course
which is pretty underwhelming like that
the culmination of brans training is him
sitting being bait nothing more than the
MacGuffin on wheels did Jojen and Hodor
and brand's personality die for this
the dead are held back by the fiery
trench but the knight King orders them
to form a bridge of corpses part of why
the whites are scary is that they have
human bodies but no humanity they're
just mindless machines with no
self-preservation and no mercy the dead
assault the walls and the heroes hack
and slash a bunch of times we see
characters facing certain death covered
in whites but then someone saves them
with one sword stroke or the cameras
cuts away and it's scary the first few
times but soon it's clear that none of
the main characters are in real danger
Lyanna Mormont the young lady of bear
I'll dies killing a white giant Liana
had always talked Big Talk
now she follows through with action
giving her life to defend the north
there are hints in the books that
tormund might be Li Anna's father go
watch that video so it's cool that last
episode
tormund claimed to have killed a giant
now his possible daughter leiana has
also killed a giant it must run in the
family
The Hound freaks out he's afraid of fire
since his brother the mountain burned
his face in season 2 the Hound ran from
the Battle of Blackwater because of this
fear but when the Hound sees aya in
trouble he overcomes his fear and rushes
to help her so again aya inspires the
Hound to be a braver better man aya does
some sick ninja moves using all her
training with the faceless men they
taught her how to fight with staffs and
to fight in the dark but she takes a
blow to the head and retreats to the
Winterfell library for a stealth section
like the kitchen scene in Jurassic Park
she silently kills a white and gently
lowers it to the ground this is an
intimate dance with death Aya's Ark is
all about the deaths of her friends the
deaths of her enemies now she gets
dangerously close to her own death when
she's overwhelmed the Hound and barracks
save her
berrak gives up his last life
sacrificing himself in a jesus tipos
barrack believed that the Lord of Light
had a special plan for him and that's
why he was resurrected six times turns
out his special destiny was to save aya
you'd think that God could have just cut
out the middleman and resurrected aya if
needed but since when were gods
efficient aya sees Melisandre they met
before in season 3 Melisandre had told
her that she would shot many eyes
forever including blue eyes she also
reminds aya of something serious ed what
do we say to the god of death
not today so Mel is hinting that I is
destiny is to kill the night king the
blue-eyed embodiment of death of course
these scenes were shot before the
showrunners decided to have our kill the
night king so they're sort of red conned
into something that sounds relevant
Melisandre changes the wording of the
eyes quote to emphasize the blue eyes
the series spent seven seasons setting
up John and Daenerys as the forces
debate the White Walkers but now at the
last minute they shoehorn Arya in as
though she was foreshadowed from the
start in the skies the dragons dance
there hasn't been a dragon fight in
Westeros for over a hundred years and
has never been a fight with a zombie
dragon
Daenerys his dragon wounds the zombie
dragon for sehri on ripping off half his
face but John's dragon Rhaegar is also
hurt and crashes with Jon to the ground
Daenerys his dragon burns the night king
but he's unhurt and smirks like an anime
villain John chases the night King on
foot so the night King raises all the
dead zombies heed Liana and kono all
rise to fight their former allies John
is completely surrounded by zombies but
when the camera cuts back he is fine
John has survived so many unsurvivable
situations lately that it's getting hard
to care when he's in danger
Daenerys lands her dragon and it's
swamped by zombies like ants over a
lizard Daenerys falls off dragon she
should really strap herself onto a
saddle like the old tug Ariens did Joris
Khaleesi sends tingles and he rushes to
help her Jorah ultimately dies
protecting Daenerys which is about the
best death he could have hoped for
he's always been defined by his loyalty
to his Khaleesi so he dies as he lived
meanwhile Tyrion Sansa Merce and I Vera
son Gilly hide in the crypts Tyrion
wants to help the battle somehow but
Sansa says they can't do anything so
they don't tyrion jokes that he and
Sansa should have stayed married but
Santa says it wouldn't work because of
Tyrians divided loyalties he's more
loyal to Daenerys than to the Starks the
show seems to be setting up conflict
between Daenerys a-squad and John's and
Tyrion is at its center when the night
King raises the dead the dead Starks in
the crypts also rise who would have
thought that a
full of corpses would be dangerous with
an icy necromancer on the loose Sansa
and Tyrion share a moment of tenderness
holding dragonglass daggers some viewers
saw this like they were about to kill
themselves but a behind the scenes
feature suggests that they're actually
about to fight the zombies in some cut
footage the living are overwhelmed by
the dead and John tries to get to bran
he sees Sam almost killed by whites but
doesn't help him which in bird culture
is considered a dick move John ends are
pinned by the wounded zombie dragon fire
streams from its neck where it was bit
by dragon the walkers reached the
godswood and Theon is the last Ironborn
standing bran tells Theon that he's a
good man and that Winterfell is his home
all Theon ever wanted was a home and a
family that accepted him that tension is
what led him to betray the Starks and
take Winterfell from bran but now bran
forgives him Theon finally gets his
Redemption and is killed by the night
king in book 5 Theon stands in this
godswood and prays for a sword let me
die as Theon not as reek and now he gets
his wish the night King approaches bran
in ultra slow motion he's waited 8,000
years for this
so like any super villain he takes his
sweet time he and bran represent
powerful magical forces bran the
three-eyed Raven holds the world's
memory and history whatever that means
and the night king is an ancient-weapon
who turned on his creators the children
of the forest just as the night King is
about to kill bran Iyer leaps from
nowhere and attacks
the night King catches ire but she drops
her dagger into a off hand and stabs the
night king in the same place where the
dragonglass that created him was also
stabbed
Aya's Valyrian knife was originally used
in an attempt on brans life now aya uses
the knife to save brans life and the
knife has a much older history Sam once
found a book connecting the knife to the
ancient Targaryen who took Westeros 300
years ago the shore run is hinted that
the hilt of this blade is made from the
same chunk of dry
glass that created the night King and so
he was unmade by the same dragon glass
that created him the night King is
destroyed and all his Walkers and wines
fall just like in the Phantom Menace aya
ends the great war and Melisandre walks
out into the dawn she dedicated her life
to winning this war
she is hundreds of years old essentially
a slave to her God now with a purpose
finally fulfilled
Melisandre lets herself rest she reverts
to her true ancient form and dies in the
snow so this episode brings a neat end
to the arcs of Melisandre Theon and
Jorah but what does it mean for the main
characters and the White Walkers and a
game of Thrones itself in recent seasons
there's a lot of foreshadowing leading
up to aya killing the night king in the
godswood bran gave aya her Valyrian
knife in the godswood last season and he
can tell he had a special purpose in
mind then eius up on jon in the godswood
just as she sneaks up on the night king
and aya uses the same hand switching
trick with a knife on Brienne that she
uses on the night king aya trained for
seasons to be a stealthy deadly assassin
her story is about death and the night
king is the embodiment of death maybe
now that she has killed him aya can let
go of her vengeance quest and start to
reconnect with her humanity so from the
perspective of IU's story her killing
the night king makes a lot of sense but
what does it mean for Jon and Daenerys
it's clear from the start that Jon and
Daenerys are central to the magic and
prophecy in this story the Song of Ice
and Fire
Daenerys was miraculously reborn unburnt
with dragons beneath a bleeding star Jon
Snow was resurrected like Christ he's
been fighting the dead since season one
and he's faced off the night king
repeatedly John and Danny both come from
the ancient magic Targaryen bloodline
and there's a prophecy hinting that they
will save the world from the white
walkers with some magic sacrifice the
show doesn't mention the prophecy stuff
as much as the books do but it's still
heavily hinted that
feeding the walkers is John and Danny's
destiny so it's pretty crazy that John
and Danny not only don't kill the night
king but they're barely involved in the
end like while aya saves the world Danny
is crying over sir friendzone and John
is yelling at a dragon it's not clear if
John and Danny even helped beat the
walkers at all like yeah they gathered
the armies and helps fight the dead but
that was always a losing battle just a
ploy to lure the night king if John and
Danny weren't there at all the night
king still would have come for bran and
aya still could have killed him right
John and Danny represent the Song of Ice
and Fire and yet they played only minor
roles in its climax the showrunner said
they had aya killed the night king
because it was unexpected and Game of
Thrones has always had surprising twists
like when the main character Ned Stark
died in season 1 and the deaths of
Catelyn and Rob are the red wedding but
those twists had meaning they showed how
honor and love can get you killed in a
world of treacherous politics what's the
meaning of our jumping from nowhere to
kill the night king that it's cool to be
a ninja that I is dehumanizing murderous
hate fueled quest was good and where
does that leave John and Daenerys if
their destiny isn't about beating the
White Walkers what is it about taking
the Iron Throne because the whole point
of the Walkers is to show that the
throne is irrelevant human greed and
pride will only lead to our
self-destruction the walkers are an
apocalyptic threat that forces humanity
to abandon their petty power struggles
and unite the north the wildlings and an
heiress come together to face a true
enemy but suddenly that's all over in
episode 3 so will John and Danny now
fight another war for the throne against
Cersei why include the White Walkers in
the story if they're just a stepping
stone to another petty war was the
ancient ice demon apocalypse just a
warm-up for the real war against a drunk
queen and her pal the horny pirate
Thrones author George Martin says his
series will end like the Lord of the
Rings books with the Scour
of the Shia in the final chapters of
rings after the good guys bait Sauron
the hobbits return to the Shire and have
to deal with Saruman it's a bittersweet
epilogue that shows that the world is
saved but it's also changed and it's
heroes have to may be Thrones will do
something similar
the big bad White Walkers are defeated
but taking Cersei off the throne will be
a time to reflect on how the last eight
seasons of scarred Westeros and its
people but there are three long episodes
left and if they're filled with more big
battles and power struggles that would
undercut the whole point of the Walkers
as a metaphor of how terrible and
pointless war is we also learned nothing
new about the White Walkers no great
revelations of their motivations or
origins nothing about these spirals or
the babies or the deeper mysteries
hinted in the books and maybe that's
fine the White Walkers aren't characters
they're a device like zombies and other
stories their purpose is to push the
human characters to extremes to show
what they're really made of and make
them do extraordinary things but in this
episode the main characters did nothing
new Jon and Daenerys were brave iowa's
badass Tyrion drink wine bran was
confusing
we did get neat conclusions for Theon
and Jorah and barrack and Mel but these
are secondary characters you think the
final confrontation with the ultimate
bad guys should have brought out
something climactic from the main
characters you'd also think that at
least one main character would have died
but in the end the White Walkers just
didn't impact the story that much Walder
Frey killed more important characters
than the knight King did all the walkers
really did was bring Jon and Daenerys
together and if Jon and Danny's alliance
just leads to more war it's hard to see
the point
and I'm sure maybe they'll be a twist
maybe the night king will respawn at the
spiral tree for round two and some
climax with John and Danny might happen
after all maybe bran was up to something
with his magic we still don't know what
he was doing all battle or what his arc
is meant to mean and we'll just have to
wait and see
of thrones ends in a few weeks the game
of thorns books go deep into prophecy
with intricate hints and symbolism but
were also warned against prophecy one of
the coolest characters in the blog suit
doesn't appear in the show is Marwan the
mage a sort of rogue professor a
paranoid maverick Meister he talks about
the prophecy of azor Ahai that hints
that John or Daenerys will beat the
White Walkers and he says he doesn't
trust it he compares prophecy to a
treacherous woman who gives pleasure
until her teeth snap shut there is a
nature of prophecy prophecy will bite
your prick off every John you can hear
all about Marwan and azor Ahai for free
today
by signing up for a trial with audible
members get a book each month and if you
cancel you keep the books you can read
in the car or the gym or while you chill
out and wait for your sister to save the
world
sign up at audible.com slash ASX thanks
for watching
we're holding live streams right after
each episode of Thrones and patreon
supporters can watch past live streams
thanks to patrons paid Amihan Emily
McNally Sandra Laing Marion Patrick long
Robert gain and cool Oh two one Oh
Cheers
you